(Brady: Got your paper all ready?)
- It's nearly
ready, it keeps curling up.
- (It's a curly one that one, I'm sorry.)
These are called Lucas-Carmichael numbers.
So they're named
after two very famous mathematicians,
Édouard Lucas and Robert Daniel
Carmichael. So if you have a composite
number, which we'll call n, and so it's
got some prime factors, so we have a
composite integer.
- (A number that's not prime?)
It's not prime, right, because it's
made up of prime
numbers, it's made up of
prime factors. Then what makes it a
Lucas-Carmichael
number is p plus 1
is a factor of n plus 1. Shall I give
you an example?
- (Yes, please.)
The smallest value n
can have actually is 399, so it sort of
gives you
a flavour that these are not everyday
numbers right? They're not- there's
398 have
gone before them without this being
satisfied. So what is- what are the prime
factors of 399? Well it's 3 times 7 times
19. So what do I do? I now
add 1, it becomes
400. And 400 has factors of 4, which is 3
plus 1, 8 which is 7 plus 1, and 20. We
know that 20 goes into 400, we know that
8 goes into 400, it goes 50 times, and we
know that 4 goes into 400.
- (So they're not the only factors?)
They're not the only factors
and they're not prime
factors of course, they are just the
factors. But the key thing- the the neat
thing is that I've added 1 to the number
and it turns out that by- that all the
the original prime factors, if I just add
1 to them, they are also factors of my
new number. That's one example, let's do
another one. So 935 for example. That has
prime factors which are 5 times 11 times
17. And if I add 1 I got 936, and the
factors of 936 include 5 plus 1, 11 plus
1 which is 12, and 17 plus 1 which is 18.
You can play around with them as much as
you like but they're not that easy to
find. So 2015, and if I
add 1 then 2016.
So this has got 4 digits so- and
these have got 3 factors; and the
smallest Lucas-Carmichael number with 5
factors is in fact 588455, and
that's made up of 5 times 7 times 17 times
23 times 43. And so if I add 1
then it has factors 5 plus 1 is 6, 7 plus
1 is 8, 17 plus 1 is 18, 23 plus 1 is 24,
and 43 plus 1 is 44.
(Are there a lot of these things?
Do we know much about them or-?)
I don't think a great deal is
known about them; that they-
they're there, they're out there, and
they're not that common I think. I think
the idea of having a number made up of
prime factors and adding 1 and all the
prime factors, if you just add 1 to
each of those prime factors, still
remains a factor of that number - it's not
at all obvious to me that it should do
that. And in fact it's clearly not that
common that it does it.
Numberphile is a collaboration
with the Mathematical
Sciences Research Institute, but it's
also made possible thanks to you the
viewers. Especially these people who've
supported us on Patreon. Our thanks to
them.
[Preview] We could at least ask, as we go
along in the sequence do we get a new
prime at each step?